today we've been waiting for the moment
for me to come out and talk to you guys
look this is the beginning of the
ability for me to address and defend
myself we have an indictment we have all
we have the information that the
government wants to come after me on and
I'm going to comply I've been confined
throughout this entire process I have no
desire not to comply at this point
they've been gracious in there now I'm
gonna have to go and fight to defend
myself the reality is is sorry it's a
witch hut because
it makes no sense that in four months
four months five months I'm indicted you
have Joe Biden's entire family receiving
deposits
non-family members receiving money from
forest from foreign destinations into
their bank accounts it's been years of
exposing a lot of you here have reported
on them and yet no investigation is
launched into them I'm gonna fight you I
well and I'm just going I'm getting back
there I'm gonna fight my battle I'm
gonna deliver I'm gonna fight the witch
said I'm gonna take care of clearing my
name and I look forward to doing that
hold on hold on hold on hold on what do
you say to that I would like the
opportunity for some of you guys to ask
some questions in an orderly fashion and
we'll start right now
why would you apply for unemployment
benefits When you had a job making 102
Rachel this is
accurate information and I will get to
clear my name on this during the
pandemic it wasn't very clear I don't
understand where the government's
getting their information but I will
present my prosecutors
say that you got over twenty thousand
dollars in unemployment benefits sir how
is that acceptable ma'am like I said my
employment was changed during the time I
don't understand where the government's
coming from Miles
what evidence
oh I I have plenty of evidence that we
will now be sharing with the government
in this case
like I said I will be giving them all or
be delivering all the finances of my
company or delivering all my finances to
them to dispel uh their their accusation
against it and again you will not I will
not rely
donations and use that money to buy
expensive suits no I did not do you
think you'll win the election
that's not up for me to know elections
are very tricky and it's up to the
people I trust them to decide what's
best time
in the past right what do you think will
make people believe you this time around
well look like I said uh I've asked many
times I want to be judged by the work I
do in the body and I I stay committed to
that Mr Santos are you headed to
Washington now yes I am I have to go
back and vote tomorrow we have uh one of
the most consequential votes in in this
Congress which is a border Bill and I'm
very looking forward to being there to
vote speaker right now well I'm not
going to address just the speaker I'll
address leadership I appreciate
everybody's patience with with my
presence in Congress as you know the
media has it's it's you know ways of
doing things and I respect you guys I've
maintained good report with a lot of you
guys I've spoken with a lot of you guys
and I have the intention to continuing
that Open Door some of you who are from
the hill know how to to find me some of
you here from the district don't have a
hard time finding me it's about keeping
in line of communication so I appreciate
leadership for being patient at this
time and for allowing the process to
play out I think this is about innocent
until proven guilty this starts I have
my right to fight to prove my innocence
as the government has the right to fight
to try to find me guilty in whatever
well because the media is not jury or
judge so I will present that to the
jurors and to the judge in this
Courthouse
if Congress requested
negotiate a plea I'm feeling lucky it's
hard
I'm addressing one of your colleagues
yeah I don't want to give the backup
here are the cameras so
as usual already I I do my best to be a
positive person life is already as bad
as it gets it slips I'm moving so I I'm
fine I'm good I believe
the way I look at it I'll be a chairman
of a committee in a couple of years if
you just look at the standards of
Congress look at the Senate
[Music]
money yet you're being alleged well it's
the legs right so are you accusing me
are you are you gonna allow the process
to play itself and allow me to carry my
names
well it's alleged right so it's so are
you accusing me are you are you gonna
allow the process to play itself and
allow me to clear my names that's my
questions
we clearly came right under your nose
to represent my district I'm going to
keep fighting to deliver results and now
I have to keep fighting to deliver uh
you know to defend my innocence and I'm
gonna do that
you should resign and put your District
out of its misery will you do that
Governor holkle is entitled to her
opinion I don't represent her she is not
my constituent so
I saw your face
you looked
go ahead you look pretty stressed
when I saw you sit down and The Judge
first started speaking what was going
through your mind what are you feeling
after being in court today well when
it's your first time in experiencing
something of this nature I think
everybody would show some kind of stress
right I I quite frankly don't believe I
was stressed I did the best I could so
just keep my composure I was I was fine
um but again this is this has been an
experience you know for a book or
something like that anyway
I appreciate you guys I appreciate you
guys here's what we'll do
guys
guys I will you see that is information
you'll never get because that is the
media's your intention is to go harass
them and make their life miserable
you're not getting that all right George
where's your husband